ils sont le visage de moins en moins
caché du manque de logements abordable
le jour ils arpente la ville la nuit est
souvent passée dans un abri de fortune
une crise qui frappe non seulement
Montréal mais aussi plusieurs villes de
régions comme Mont-Laurier et
Saint-Jérôme
et en 2022 même des gens qui travaillent
peuvent se retrouver à la rue
en excluant la fin de covid-19 là
c'était pas évidentes
actuellement puis surtout quelqu'un qui
est comme affablement
c'est le cas de frank Lambert il a vécu
4 épisodes d'Itinérances et pendant
plusieurs semaines en 2020 il dormait la
nuit dans les rues du quartier qu'il
était payé pour nettoyer le jour
mais il a finalement trouvé une chambre
à moins de 500 dollars par mois dans un
bâtiment géré par l'Accueil Bonneau un
petit foyer modeste mais qui lui évite
de retourner à la rue moi ça me donne
donc si je tombe sur son mandalaire puis
tu vas avoir un loyer 900 dollars
sans logement abordable Franck
retomberait probablement dans un cercle
vicieux les douloureux aller-retours
entre la rue et des logements trop chers
pour ce petit salarié
pour combattre le problème on tente de
construire ici 39 logements sociaux
après judiciaire pour leur vie sortir de
la rue sortir d'une situation qui a
aucun sens où ils sont abusés par
d'autres propriétaires mais le projet
est ralenti la présence d'amiante
complique les rénovations qui prennent
beaucoup plus de temps que prévu en
principe ça devrait être fonctionnel
mais c'est sûr que là il y a eu pandémie
on a eu beaucoup de délais de gros
délais et une hausse des coûts qui
dépasse les prévisions d'environ 20% un
coup de pouce qu'on a besoin qui voit à
peu près 50 000 par unité de logement on
se rappelle qu'on a un 39 logements donc
grosso modo à peu près 2 millions sur 12
millions de dollars un problème qui
touche la majorité des projets de
logements social Lancy depuis le début
de la pandémie en 2020 et 2021 le coût
de réalisation moyen d'un logement
social était de 213000 dollars cette
année la facture à grimper à 338000
dollars une explosion de 58%. en deux
ans le coût des matériaux donc les
fournisseurs en ont profité et plus
récemment on vit les contrecoups d'une
augmentation des taux d'intérêt qui ont
un impact sur l'hypothèque que les
organismes ont un pays ultimement le CAC
prévoyait livrer quelques 14000
logements sociaux entre 2018 et 2022
mais seul 4300 finalement été construit
résultat plus de gens se retrouve dans
les hébergements dit temporaire bien des
intervenants du secteur pensent qu'il
faut briser ce cercle vicieux réduire
l'investissement en hébergement
d'urgence pour proportionnellement
augmenter l'investissement en logement
abordable donc Toronto Calgary le pays
la Finlande en fait ont tous fait ce
virage là puis on drastiquement réduit
leur coûts du service de santé service
sociaux servaient judiciaire
depuis qu'il a trouvé son logement
Franck a payé ses contraventions ils ne
consomme pas d'alcool et échafaudes ces
projets si je réussis peut-être faire
sortir de Montréal ou faire avoir des
voyages quelque part mais au moins pour
le moment parce qu'il est plus gros est
fait parce que j'ai plein de conseils à
tête au niveau stabilité de logement
[Musique]